ce que pendant le ramadan il ya un
principe des repas de rupture du jeûne
qui était quelque chose de très
important dans la tradition dans
l'esprit les notions de partage et de
générosité lors des opérations de
distribution de boxe de pâques et des
iftars boxe que les personnes viendront
chercher avant l'heure de rupture du
jeûne et qu'elles récupéreront pour
manger à la maison
seul et puis il ya aussi des opérations
de distribution dans des zones où il ya
des concentrations de personnes un petit
peu dans des situations précaires et
vulnérable ce sont les foyers de
travailleurs isolés et là il y aura des
distributions avec certaines
associations du cam en partenariat avec
d'autres associations humanitaires
locales
un des dessins de l'islam de la
législation islamique c'est la
préservation de la vie humaine la
préservation de la vie humaine passe
avant tout et avant certaines choses qui
paraissent obligatoire qui sont
obligatoires qui sont préférables comme
les prières collectives qui sont
obligatoires certes mais la préservation
de la vie humaine passe avant cela et
c'est pour cela que nous avions fermé la
mosquée avant le début du confinement et
c'est pour ça que les mosquées resteront
fermées pendant le mois du ramadan et je
profite de cette audience pour rappeler
à tous les musulmans qui écouteront cela
que c'est vrai qu'avec les beaux jours
on peut considérer qu'on sort plus
facilement mais non il faut faire
attention pour rester confiné il faut
faire attention parce qu'on peut être un
vecteur aussi de mal aux pour ses
proches et pour la société en général
donc profitons en pour faire une
introspection pour peut-être plus lire
le coran
le mouvement du ramadan est le mois de
la lecture du coran peut être revoir nos
pratiques religieuses mais en tout cas
pas de pratique collective